ich würde sehr dafür plädieren dass wir
in dieser situation in der wir jetzt
sind die 80 jahre in der unsere werte
frieden und die art wie wegen der
gesellschaft zusammenleben dass wir
darauf stolz sind dass wir korrigieren
wo wir versäumnisse haben ohne uns zu
verurteilen indem wir unsere
verteidigung stärken indem wir
militärisch besser werden als wir das
waren aber wir sollten erkennen dass wir
in der demokratie versäumt haben
spielregeln einzuführen die eine
sollbruchstelle für autokraten
rechtzeitig geben ich glaube als
juristin wage ich zu behaupten dass wir
in der lage sind solche sollbruchstellen
verfassungsrechtlich einzubauen in den
säulen presse justiz polizei und militär
die ein autokrat braucht um ein volk zu
unterdrücken muss man bereits bei der
einschränkung der pressefreiheit
einschreiten können zum beispiel durch
neu war enorm matter what ob der gute
oder schlechte absichten hat weil in der
zweiten amtszeit etablieren sie es und
wir sehen es immer wieder und dann
nutzen sie die staatsgewalt gegen die
bürger die sich dagegen wehren wollen
und die sie gewählt haben eine zweite
möglichkeit von der ich glaube dass sie
notwendig ist wir sollten unsere
bewerbungsprozess für politikerinnen
professionalisieren wir sollten schauen
dass bewerbungen ähnlich wie in der
wirtschaft wie wir alle davon betroffen
sind in einem rahmen stattfinden aber
braucht eine arbeitsplatzbeschreibung
was erwarten wir von einem politiker von
einer politikerin die muss der wähler
leisten und dann im nächsten schritt
muss ein bewerbungsprozess da sein der
wie überall stattfindet mit einem
lebenslauf mit zeugnissen mit nachweisen
wo ich gearbeitet habe und das ist von
den parteien zu leisten dass das
tatsächlich auch richtig gemacht wird
nur ein beispiel
den gerichte haben darüber entschieden
dass mein bewerbungen kein foto das
einen darf und menschen nicht zu
beeinflussen die politik arbeitet mit
plakaten als einem der obersten überall
an wenn wahlen sind machen diesen
gesicht dann mit irgendeinem kleinen
komischen begriff drunter oder sonstwas
und in der in der wirtschaft wir alle
müssen uns nicht mit fotos bewerben aus
gutem grund weil das soll die leute
nicht beeinflussen ich finde da ist zum
beispiel ein nachholbedarf und es wäre
eine maßnahme uns um unsere demokratie
zu stabilisieren
in der nächsten sendung
zu stehen wir sind ja schon ich werde
mir ganz neues gesicht das allein aber
das also man kann glaube ich eine
demokratie oder ein demokratisches
auswahlverfahren durch die bevölkerung
nicht vergleichen mit einem
bewerbungsverfahren in einem unternehmen
weil naja weil dort die bevölkerung
entscheidet da hat jeder auch eigene
kriterien das heißt zum beispiel haben
sagen sie vielleicht wenn sie ihr kreuz
abgeben da ist für mich das kriterium
wichtig welche wirtschaftskompetenz hat
die person oder die partei für eine
andere zelle lona ist aber vielleicht
wichtig macht die person etwas für den
sozialstaat und für eine dritte person
ist vielleicht interessant wie verhält
sich der politiker oder die partei sie
sind aber falschen ebene ich rede davon
dass von vornherein geklärt sein muss
ich sage ja nicht dass das alles nichts
mehr darüber entscheiden soll darüber
entscheiden wie ist es denn ich habe
einen lebenslauf ich habe in meinem
leben was gemacht und ich sage nichts
anderes als dass das in einem genormten
verfahren bei jedem politiker
politikerinnen da sein muss und es darf
nicht jeder selber bestimmen was er ins
netz stellt was er den leuten erzählt
dann leben sie die axt an die demokratie
veränderst du dich in sachen demokratie
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass sich jede
frau jeder mann bewerben kann der
nachweis von qualität kann ja trotzdem
der wähler entscheidet ja aber der
nachweis von qualität darf einem doch
deshalb nicht oder von überhaupt was wer
ist es der dabei was es noch alles
ausmacht entscheiden doch die wähler das
ist jeder wähler hat doch eigentlich
kriterien ja sagen nur dass sie in
der sendung wie hier ja ich finde dass
-ausgabe auf das ganze problem über das
sie sprechen das finde ich eine ganz
ganz wichtige frage im gerade in dem
kontext was wir diskutiert haben auch
dass wir wirklich in der situation sind
weltweit wo der kampf ist zwischen
freiheit und diktatur und wo wir mit
china erstmals haben eine diktatur die
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich ist dass wir
weiter so wird nun anders also von daher
muss alles getan werden um die
demokratie machen